and finally new rule the tycoons of
social media have to stop pretending
that they're friendly nerd God's
building a better world and admit
they're just tobacco farmers and
t-shirts selling an addictive product to
children because let's face it
checking your likes is the new smoking a
recent 60 Minutes segment exposed what's
called brain hacking how everything
Silicon Valley develops is purposely
designed to make us feel compelled to
check in constantly they want you to use
it in particular ways and for long
periods of time because that's how they
make their money every time I check my
phone I'm playing the slot machine to
see where did I get this is one way to
hijack people's minds and create a habit
to form a habit that's right Apple
Google Facebook they are essentially
drug dealers and I thought where have I
heard that before oh yeah on 60 minutes
I'm going to make a team delivery
business and that's what cigarettes are
for most certainly it's a delivery
device for nicotine yep it was never
about smooth tobacco flavor it was about
the nicotine and the other drugs that
cigarette makers deliberately put in to
make it addictive the moral rot in this
country began when corporate America
decided it wasn't enough to just
successfully sell your product people
needed to be addicted to it
Keibler's cookies are not really made by
elves and trees
they're engineered in labs like all
processed food with precise combinations
of salt sugar and fat that are
specifically designed to not satisfy the
reason you can eat just one pretzel is
the salt is like the nicotine in the
cigarette it's the drug and the pretzel
is the delivery system that's how
twisted pretzels are
food companies are not in the satisfying
hunger business they're in the finish
the whole bag business they're in the we
own you business you are our junkie
slave you can't resist this [ __ ] just
put it in the cart and shut up before we
make you suck your dick for it sorry
dick for it what am i you heard the guy
in the 60 minutes piece every time you
check your phone you are pulling that
slot machine handle because you might
get a reward a text a like a dick pic
from Anthony Weiner we all know the
feeling you post a picture on social
media and when the likes pop up it
floods your brain with gratifying
dopamine Facebook purposely holds back
the likes sometimes so you will keep
checking how come my friends didn't love
that picture of my soup what's wrong
with me oh wait wait wait oh do they see
this picture of my water bottle it's
come to this you don't exist until you
get a smiley face and then that's not
enough you need a thumbs up or better a
giant thumbs up a giant black thumbs up
this is why the average person interacts
with their phone over 2,600 times a day
it wants all your attention all the time
it's not a service it's Glenn Close in
fatal attraction I'm not going to be
ignored
a third of Americans check the phone
during meals
19% have checked it in church mostly
grinder
pedestrian deaths are way up because
people in the crosswalk looking down are
getting run over by drivers looking down
the whole damn country is constantly
looking down there is something being
crushed out there but it ain't candy
Philip Morris just wanted your lungs the
AppStore wants your soul